Another way of thinking of this is
that tracking is just an induction,
a process, right?
An induction, like for math is if I know
how to do n then I know how to do n + 1.
When you show what the sum of a
geometric series is or things like that,
you tend to prove these things by
induction or something like that.
So for induction,
you have to have a starting case,
a base case so you have some
guess as to how things start.
Maybe for our tracking,
we have some distribution.
It could be a very
uncertain distribution.
And then, with that first frame,
we take a measurement, y zero and
then we would correct our estimate.
And then we just keep
iterating through this.
Right?
So,
At every time t, we make a prediction
for time t plus 1, take a measurement,
and we correct for time t plus 1.
And somebody spent a lot of time
designing these beautiful arrows, so
I wanted to make sure you saw them too.
And if you go take a look all over
the internet, you'll find these arrows.